Tesla's been promising an affordable
long range electric vehicle for years
Chevrolet might have just beaten it to
the
punch this is the allnew Chevrolet bolt
a battery powered car that'll travel 200
M between charges that's more than
double the range of the ultra popular
Nissan Leaf how'd Chevy do it a new
Ultra efficient battery and a host of
lightweight materials it even cut vents
in the fender so the car would carry
less metal the interior is space aged
the seats float on ribs of metal a
smartphone can be programmed to act as a
key fob and the door panels glow the
most critical feature however is the
price Chevy says the car will cost about
$330,000 that's after a $7,500 federal
tax rebate at the moment however the
bolt is just a concept so you won't see
in dealerships for at least a year in
the meantime however Tesla's unn
[Music]
yes